a night of intensive air attacks in and
around the port city of Odessa Ukraine
says grain handling facilities were the
target
Ukrainian commanders say dozens of
drones and missiles were launched by
Russia and while some were intercepted
many got through
images on social media showed damage to
Port facilities as well as buildings in
the city with reports of some civilian
casualties coming in the same week that
Russia pulled out of the Black Sea grain
deal which provided a safe shipping
Corridor for exporting Ukrainian grain
keeves says it shows moscow's disregard
for Global Food security
last night Russian Rockets targeted
Ukraine import infrastructure which is
involved in the export of food and
agrarian produce
such attacks conducted by Russia Target
not only our country but also global
stability
this was the second night of air attacks
mainly targeting Southern Ukraine in
what appeared to be Russia's promised
reprisals for the attack on the Kirch
Bridge connecting the Crimean Peninsula
on Monday Ukraine says in addition to
damage to grain handling facilities
sixty thousand tons of food was
destroyed in Tuesday night's attack the
ukrainians are accusing Russia of trying
to create a global hunger crisis Rob
McBride Al Jazeera Keith